hey hello I've reviewed every single
reddit there is on the planet except one
it was right ahead of me all along
memes the sub ready I just never touched
this cuz I assume it's awful but prove
me wrong okay
prove me wrong let's get into this me
calls my cat by name my cat doesn't give
a Frick me my cat my boyfriend said oh
my god my cat looks like baby yo then I
look over and Shirin wasn't of course
it's cat jokes I don't know what else we
expected here but it's still funny
alright I don't even like cats but they
make me life me and never thought I'd
end the decades tied by side with the
girlfriend my crush what about it how
about that I expected a train wreck but
it I'm cracking up Hey look another cat
one me meows to my cat my cat hearing me
make pen grammatical errors in just one
meow how embarrassing I'm laughing on
the inside
Jim company's on the first of January
2020 it do be like that for anyone that
goes regularly to the gym you can tell
obviously it no but it's so annoying
it's like all the sudden the whole thing
is just packed and it's like just leave
we know you're not gonna be here just go
I will give you this money if you tell
us something about the new Star Wars
film I hear they are making another one
what don't make it I know that Star Wars
film I haven't seen it yet I can't wait
to see it because I hear it's terrible
and my expectations are already so low
what they made another bad Star Wars
film well then you're a I'm sorry
I haven't even seen it literally anybody
comes over to her house grandma so
anyway I started baking would you like
some pie that's good good me if you kill
a killer the number of killers in the
world remains the same Batman but what
if I kill two killers what that happened
then mr. Batman huh not so big brain now
are we mr. batiste
a spider mimicking an ant by holding its
front leg as an antenna how do you know
how how's it doing it oh it's just doing
that okay I thought it was holding the
legs of an ant to pretend to be an end
that would that I had a respect I'd be
like Jesus Christ
it isn't child chokes to death on can be
Oompa Loompas so anyway I started
dancing I don't know why you but I feel
like the instrument rip off my shirt in
the process high school portrayed in
anime high school portrayed in movies
high school in real life I haven't been
happy one minute surely high school
can't be bad for everyone
why is everyone pretending like they're
the Joker like that's the
relatability is it because everyone on
red is a loser is that why is
that it cuz then come here brethren
let's hug it out
I got to get some more drink actually
well I got my drink this this got me
thinking all right remember remember
what are you what do you don't remember
cuz you didn't experience this Zoomers
remember when he was actually frowned
upon to be a nerd okay
I remember because I lived through that
alright then shows like OC came out with
like Seth Cohen that guy being a nerd
and still kind of cool and quirky right
before then you had that you were
ashamed to admit you play video games
basically right and if you're listening
to this thinking no I'm never about to
ask if you didn't live through it okay I
paved that path for you you're welcome
okay years of suffering this whole Joker
appropriating of oh he's so he's so he's
so sad and still so epic you're welcome
okay
don't take that for granted you know how
in America you have all the oil thank
the troops here thank the Nerds okay
maybe I went a little far on that but
you it's just an analogy you understand
okay the reason why goals don't kill
people in real life is because they did
these people would become ghosts anymore
[Music]
hey man sorry bye kid
what are you doing what are you doing
sit down sit down I spill a little water
on him and look at him
what are you doing I don't you ruin my
joke
you ruined my joke I hope you're happy
it's gonna make a whole spiel about
ghosts and all pit bull owners there are
no bad dogs only bad owners she was I
never seen a well-behaved Chihuahua
doesn't exist the FBI agent when they
hear me get laid through my Google home
speech and other fictions written
through memes sure moving on got'em I I
like baby odor and I like the
mandalorian I finally watched a finally
watch it's really good at least the
first couple episode but I don't I
realized I don't mind baby odor I just
don't like the memes okay they're so bad
they're bad let's just admit let's just
get the cow out of the bag that's not
the expression but whatever you
understand what I'm saying
when you had a great day at school but
then your mom yells at you right out
there after you enter your house yep oh
this is so sad when you get nominated
for Mima the decade out of nowhere
surprise no it's not meme of the decade
come on don't even try surprise yourself
back to dead lion because you don't
belong make game publisher this game has
85 hours of gameplay speedrunners three
take it or leave it
publisher this game has 85 hours of of
dragged-out cutscenes and repeatable
events that are super boring I've seen
this everyone team trees reaching 20
million Wikipedia asking for two points
I did donate to the kefir yeah I know
I'm kind of ashamed and I didn't even
tell anyone about it the Xbox one game I
got for Christmas me who has a
Playstation it's always like oh I
remember what I was talking about the
worst gifts we got and I couldn't think
of any but then I remember my dad once
gave me the Gameboy he came by a home
from a trip and he gave me a gameboy and
was amazed I was like oh my god this is
the greatest thing ever right and he's
got the new Super Mario on it right it's
amazing but it wasn't Super Mario it was
dr. Mario but it was still such a nice
gift that I learned to love dr. Mario
it's
great game done I still was slapping and
you know it
co-worker posted pictures of himself and
random places when he quit found this at
the back of a clock from two years ago
everywhere I go I see his face sometimes
we don't need this bit of the meme it
doesn't make it funnier stop it stop it
it was funny before you try to make a
meme out of it actually wasn't read it's
new prints playstation or xbox pc he
said shouts and why he's so down with us
cuz i am on a PC PC master-race
am i right this is getting a little
stale let's jump over to dank memes
alright dank memes don't let me down now
boy
it's basically what it's called
pewdiepie submissions these are still
going everyone else complaining about
not getting coins me not knowing what
coins do what do they do
I don't understand US government letting
people under 21 drink alcohol letting
people under 21 smoke cigarettes letting
18 year olds take on a lifetime of debt
for an education
letting 18 year olds die overseas in a
war started before they were born
wait I thought they didn't let people
under 21 drink in America I'm so
confused then yeah a lot of a lot is
that the government does it's just
excuses to tax like in Sweden
we can buy alcohol when we're 18 but we
can't buy alcohol until we're 21 in
stores we just have to buy it from bars
and that makes so much sense that my
brain almost explodes from sense says
being a crappy neighbor lesson one
French nuclear pop where should we put
the power plant but I thought power
plants has to be Nexus to see or
something
oh god when your old computer run for
the first time with an SSD it's funny
because it's true that's awful awful
trains are just sideways elevators that
really makes you think doesn't it
jumping is just vertical walking the
weave student singing konichiwa to the
Asian exchange student the korean
extinction konichiwa - huh
everyone annoying dude on the bus so
anyway I started blasting why do they do
that what is wrong with people have you
heard of headphones am i right what is
wrong with pitts ounds like a Seinfeld
bit so watch with these guys that blast
music in the subway have they not heard
of headphones eighteen year old boy
doesn't get into college to recruit at
the mom he'll be a soldier how about 27
year old that didn't get into med school
and thousands of dollars in depth
you'll be soldier the police in my town
just installed the speed Raider the
police in my town also have the maturity
level of teenage boy noise if you speed
twice the speed limit and more you get a
nice that's that big this makes me want
to commit some crimes I'm not gonna lie
when your friend says he's gonna sleep
but you meet him in another match I was
stood one more however I remember this
happening you say you're gonna log off
from World of Warcraft or some like
that and then you can see your friend
being a lime like how God just finishing
this quest stop talking to me 9 Journal
me closing the fridge door slowly to try
and see the light go off my god did
everyone do this I thought I was special
my face when I could realize that you
just have to press down that one button
in the corner of the fridge what the
fridge doesn't know that I opened god
help me please I'm dying from where with
obesity humid what that jug star liquor
chubby chubby just for real though I see
so many people with overweight look at
this dog looking no Chuck no Chuck
everyone has a fat pug you never seen a
pug that isn't chubby chub now you ain't
good he don't invade me shave me shut up
shut up go back to Cape it is kind of
mean to over feed your pet is what I'm
getting at and I think pugs generally I
don't need
gonna rant about bugs actually never
mind it's this generally they're all fat
okay that's all I wanted to say but
they're not supposed to be fat just
because everyone's pug is fat and they
already have breathing problems so it's
not good for them that's all I'm saying
these ready videos are just me going on
random tangents about topics that
doesn't matter Apple's most expensive
Mac Pro can cost fifty two thousand
depending on 450 mm I'll sell you a much
better computer and it comes attached to
a car money that's crazy
why the would anyone spend that
much on that computer just cuz it's a
Mac it blows my mind I'm trying to
convert Marcia to Android but man it's
hard me playing Minecraft finding the
diamond for the 4000 uh finding diamond
for the 4000 time it's funny because
it's true only real minecrafter can
understand me checking my inventory in
the middle of a boss by people who think
baby oda should be meme of the decade
literally everyone else
how do people on Iran Nicola think this
how did they come to that conclusion I'm
so confused
imagine not being able to rotate your
plug this post was made by yo plug gang
damn actually I watched Tom Scott video
and he told me that the EU plug is
actually the most superior plug because
of its safety mechanism and other things
that I don't remember but I watched a
video and enjoyed it when you go to a
friend's house only to pet his dog I
gotta say though people that get too
into petting someone else's pet at their
house it's like no listen you're here
for me alright stop petting my dog no
it's almost two people that you don't
know that well that always goes for the
dog because they don't have ya know feel
like I'm ripping on people that are
socially awkward but I don't like it
alright IKEA confesses Oh God that their
meatballs Oh God are made up people that
did if I the ex I'm okay with that I'm
alright with that that's fine that's
fair that's fair that's survival of the
fittest more ideas like this please
[Laughter]
self-driving Mercedes will be programmed
to sacrifice pedestrians sacrifice
pedestrians you meat run them over
to save the driver mersen's gets around
the moral issues of self-driving cars by
deciding that of course drivers are more
important than anyone else
Mercedes somewhere you may die but
actual sacrifice time will they this is
exactly my video and the whole moral
testing I did a year a year ago moral
machine it's this website where you you
basically answer if a car should judge
for I don't know kill the old guy or
steer the driver and I'm like well if
I'm manufacturing a car I'm not gonna
sell a product that sacrifices the
driver so it made the whole video
completely pointless I'm like kill that
kill that kill that but it seems like
Mercedes already figured out as much as
I'm a Tesla fan that by the guards that
make me respect Mercedes so much and at
least they have the balls to say it as
it is yeah I'm gonna kill the driver
he'd bought the car so happy I grew up
with this but damn this is better
nothing makes me feel like a Boomer than
trying to figure out how to add friends
on discord I still don't understand how
to do it and also the skype theme dude
do you not miss it am I the only one
dude dude what is this could have fart
noises but that's what they have stinky
discord teachers standing over be
silently me playing math cool games I
can relate it's very funny
I made a haha because of it vegans when
they discover they are made out of meat
becomes when they discover that plants
filled pain Vegas when they discover
there's car seats are made of leather
Vegas when they figure out their car is
made of dead animals skin the interior
not the machine ok when you rest your
head on the bus window alright I think
it's time to end this I think we get the
point somewhat mildly amusing browsing
this I think yes if you agreed subscribe
we got more Miley amusing conduct coming
right up gamer but not for long because
I quit quit soon hmm so you better savor
this see you tomorrow
watch another video hey bye bye
too long you have been farting in the
corner now you are entering a new era
where you shall craft thy home
the hour of fart smells and poop grades
is coming
marzia Edgar and buttons need you
the dimer you will face but crawlers is
all about
when you are seated on the porcelain
throne where T is the game to play
I'm not supposed to have my opinion
about that but the prices
[Music]
Oh